Dr Phil I heard him say God only gave
you one so pick a horse and ride it you
can't ride two horses you know and so
I've just been riding the same horse and
by the way there's a lot of times when
it's tempting to be like man still talk
about this getting bored with this but
as it goes deeper and as you build more
momentum kind of learned that from Steve
Jobs too when he left apple and then the
product lines expanded and there got all
this noise and all this destruction and
then when he came back he narrowed it
back down they fired him actually yeah
yeah I also was making an educated guest
on the horse I was betting on and that
was YouTube itself